CARTER MORGAN: We got
rid of over 600 bugs
in the last video.
So the Add a Cat to That
app should be pretty secure,
except I can't
remember if I removed
the debug switch in the
code I checked in at 2:00
AM last night.
Stick around to see
how Web Security
Scanner helps protect you from
inevitable mistakes like this.
Mistakes happen even
to the best of us.
No matter how great
developers are,
we're going to
accidentally introduce bugs
to the code base.
Luckily, Google's
Web Security Scanner
can do automatic testing to
your deployed code to find bugs
and unintentional
vulnerabilities introduced
to the code base.
It's really easy to use.
Let's see it in action.
From this simple web UI in
GCP, we create a new scan.
We point it at a
staging URL for our app,
not the production URL.
Because Cloud
Security Scanner is
going to be fuzz testing,
or throwing a whole lot
of wacky data, at our app.
And we don't want
to risk corrupting
the live version of our app.
In this example, we've put in
a Kubernetes pod address there.
I'll leave everything
else that is default
and then set Cloud Web
Security Scanner to run daily.
And after about 15
minutes, you should
be able to see what
the output looks like.
And we see here, Cloud
Web Security Scanner
found a few issues.
See, Cloud Web Security
Scanner starts crawling around
all the URLs it can find and
starts looking for these known
vulnerabilities.
Here you see it found some
cross site scripting issues.
By clicking on the
known vulnerability,
we can see the issue in
our admin login page.
Just from the UI, we're able
to dig in and get the exact way
to replicate that bug so that
we can troubleshoot and then fix
it.
So we're going to show
you this bug live.
And then we're going
to fix it right now
so that we can knock yet
another vulnerability off
of Add a Cat to That.
If we take that HTML from
Web Security Scanner,
we can see right in
our UI that instead
of showing the email address of
the person who tried to log in,
our app is displaying
weird stuff.
If we go and look at
the login page HTML,
where Web Security Scanner
got that HTML from,
we can look and see
that I accidentally
left in a safe flag which
disables cross site scripting
prevention.
Once we take that out and
push that build to production,
Web Security Scanner will
continue doing its daily scan
and letting us know about
any other vulnerabilities it
can detect.
The coolest part about this
whole process, and the tool,
is that Web Security
Scanner doesn't cost you
anything to use.
It's a free and easy low
friction fire and forget tool.
It's not perfect.
It won't protect you from
a sophisticated attack
or a new clever zero day.
But it will help you with
a lot of those common,
easy to prevent errors that
may have slipped past your code
review process.
Once you set up that daily
scan, it's going to keep going.
The supply chain is secure.
We've set up automatic
web security scans.
This app should be secure.
What's left?
Me.
Oh, me.
Phishing.
That's right.
We've protected our software.
It's time to protect
our developers.
Don't miss the next video.
We're going to talk
about preventing
one of the oldest and most
common vulnerabilities,
phishing.